saying goodbye to king ragnar was
momentous for huge for fans I'm assuming
for yourself as well saying goodbye to
your antihero it was well not really my
antihero
I mean my hero you know and it very
difficult to write that very emotional
for me
but very engaging because Travis wanted
everything he did and everything he said
in that episode to be significant and to
be and so and with Linus Roache can't
but we spent a long time going through
this scripts gonna have other scripts
rewriting putting a lot of pressure on
the script making sure that rightness
death was as poignant and as meaningful
and as devastating as it could be but in
the sense you know Ragnar never goes
away this is from the start this has
always been a story of Ragnar and his
sons and so the son said the father
lives on through the song yes sir
so he's still with us as is Ethel said
because Athelstan as well doesn't go
away well Ragnar continued to live not
only through his sons but through the
magic of television flashbacks will we
ever see him again
yeah no that's it
yeah because it's too big I think the I
think you know the audience and we've
now got a huge audience and I mean I
think now it's the fifth biggest show in
the world
you know and and so you can't cheat them
you know I established a convention
which allowed you know people say ghosts
to Alice and to appear for people to hit
his voice or occasionally to see to see
his his ghost because it's also about
subjective vision it's about what dunam
it was like the Vikings seeing Odin on
the backfield in the very beginning
which isn't magic realism it's it's not
you know it
I could put it there because that's what
the Vikings themselves said they saw so
and and you know I could bring out the
stand back but the idea of somehow
bringing Ragnar this huge presence this
person sort of dominated events for so
long to bring him back wouldn't be
wouldn't work I felt that it would it
wouldn't work it would be an anti-climax
well and it also of course it gives us
the opportunity to get to know these
other characters more and yeah watch
them rise to power and find themselves I
think either the boneless is one of the
most exciting characters to watch yeah
brutal ruthless exciting where is he
going to go in season five well isn't it
amazing that there at least one of the
heirs to the great Ragnar lothbrok and
one of the most famous Vikings of all
time was a [ __ ] who as we recall
Ragnar left outside to die when he was
born so here's we've watched his
childhood we've watched how his mother
gave him to floki to bring up in the old
ways and and and in in the deep ways and
I it's it's one of the things of course
I'm enormously proud of in the show is
that we actually do have children and
animals you know and and we're very real
and we children grow up you know and so
we've seen some of Iver start fit and
we've seen his casual cruelty but we
never lost sympathy with him because he
is a [ __ ] because he's got to try
harder than his brothers to have the
same effect and that kind of
contradiction continues as he rises to
prominence and to greater power that
it's almost almost that whatever Iver
does I was the shocking it is we could
still find in ourselves some sympathy or
he can
certainly encourage us to feel as still
some some sympathy for him he's he is in
a sense an anti-hero
I think he within the let's say within
the brothers there is sort of a liberal
wing of the Viking Party which would be
Bjorn and uber and then there's a sort
of darker more visceral more viking
vikings who would be Ivor obviously in
fits irk so but Ivor is constantly
fascinating I mean he's constantly
fascinating for me to write about partly
because you don't know what he's going
to do and he doesn't recognize yes he's
very yes he's deeply ambitious and and
he doesn't recognise any boundaries so
he doesn't recognise any boundaries to
his own rise that is to say he's not
going to be defeated by the fact that
he's a [ __ ] me but he doesn't
recognise any boundaries to morality or
anything basically you know so which
means the possibilities are endless
yeah lagertha of course you've called
her before the the soul of the show the
heart of the show takes out Ivor's
mother yes this can only lead to chaos
yes yes that's uh that was a big moment
and I think you know to her credit a
slug
you know had become a fairly formidable
person you know who had to slightly gone
on the dark side and you know but what
was interesting about like that taking
back cat cat which she thought was her
right was her decision I think to try
and rule as a intelligent woman would
rule not as a man would rule so and and
she as a consequence she takes many
decisions that other people including
some other women in the cause think are
maybe too weak
she's prepared sometimes to give people
the benefit of the doubt she's prepared
to understand where people are coming
from she's trying desperately to get
away from that in the Viking conventions
or which say that it revenge is the most
important thing you know she tries to be
even-handed and fair and intuitive when
she's dealing with you know marital
cases or problems within her society so
I I think you know whenever I'm dealing
with with legacy I'm always trying to to
push her into situations that I think
other women would identify with you know
and and and and because you know early
on after she left Ragnar because she
wouldn't put up with being you know the
second wife she was then in an abusive
relationship and well she didn't put up
with it but when I first wrote that
storyline Katherine didn't was uneasy
about it so what my fans will want me in
an abusive relationship you know and
that's that they will totally understand
that many women including many strong
women find themselves in that kind of
life it's how you deal with it that
matters so yes she's some and and she
has a chef you know lover no Astrid it's
not because she's a lesbian it's just
because she's being treated so badly by
men that it's hardly a surprise that she
would want there the company of someone
who she might be able to trust and
Astrid is you know a free-thinking young
woman who is actually partly based on on
on Astrid it was the name coach that who
photographed the Beatles in Hamburg yeah
in the early 60s and really invented
their look and was a wonderful
free-spirited young German woman and
they were absolutely enthralled by her
and she she literally reinvented them
cut their hair and that's why at one
point after it says to the sons I
love to read cousin tree mate when you
sat down to write season five was there
a particular character that you were
just you could not wait to take on an
adventure who are you most excited to
see thrive in season five well obviously
I was very excited to take Iver forward
and discover him and explore how many
boundaries he could actually break and
is there anyone happy but I like it but
I like but you know beyond is going to
go back to the Mediterranean I've been
living with these characters for so long
and it's so strange now that that
Alexander that that beyond is is older
compared to these young guys who who've
burst onto that onto the show you know
he's an elder statesman he's you know
but he's got this wanderlust that that
that Ragnar had so this is that part of
Ragnar lives on and Beyond which is the
inquiring mind the need to see other
places and have other experiences so
then that takes the show forward and
that's wonderful and then do you think
we weren't sorry to tell you but do you
think Buren has what it takes or
something inside of him to potentially
be king someday I do yeah I think he has
to I think he has to deal with his
mother yes and I'm not sure he quite
knows that yet but I think that's one
thing that he has to do but then I think
yes he can he can be king and then in
talking with Kings of course five
dealing with Wessex and dealing with the
fallout from the huge defeat at the
hands of the great he's an army which is
devastating obviously led to the death
of expert and the others as wolf being
crowd but being king of a swamp being in
mythology what was called the wounded
king and
and and basically having a breakdown
you know the said God has absolutely
deserted them and having a sick son you
know that Alfred is a subject this
strange sickness and so that was a great
story like that was a wonderful story
line and from that kind of terrible
weakness and in terms of Alfred we're
going to see Alfred slowly taking steps
to be the person who became known as
Alfred the Great said we want there is
no at the moment there's no obvious
connection between this young weak
damaged young man and someone who is
called Alfred the Great so we want to
see that what were the steps what led to
what led to do that it's interesting cuz
there's almost some parallels with Ivor
you're very different types of men and
going about it a much different way
Alfred through education and and and
religion and I ever through yeah well of
course they played chess when they were
young when Ragnar carried over into the
villa in Wessex the grand Royal Villa
and he was talking to that Ragnar was
talking to King Egbert there's one scene
where Iver and the young Alfred are
playing chess and yes says you thinking
so far ahead so they're going to play
chess on the battlefield
chuckles so I know that's kind Alfred
yes so I know that's coming